This is really great.
Joe Biden is immediately handling the pandemic
and all of these different things.
Donald Trump is in court trying to get rid
of Obamacare.
And yesterday, Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
held a press conference and they said we should
not be ending Obamacare at this point in time
now before we even get to any clips.
It was sort of jarring to see Joe and Carmela
go a half hour without insulting anybody.
And when they took questions, Joe Biden actually
answered the questions.
It was a nice change of pace.
I've just become completely unaccustomed to
it over the last four years now when Joe Biden
was asked questions.
It's crazy that this is even noteworthy.
He would listen to the question, pause to
think about an answer and then actually answer
the question.
Mind blown, right.
Incredible.
And as you can imagine, most of the questions
Joe Biden was asked were about the fact that
Trump continues to claim he won and that Biden
didn't win and Trump hasn't conceded and Joe
Biden played it really well.
Here he is answering and laughing Trump off.
And I'll tell you about the importance of
that in a moment.
Presumably, at some point you will need access
to more classified information to secure facilities
and the like.
What options are you considering?
How will you move ahead if the president continues
to refuse to concede?
Well, look, access to classified information
is is useful, but I'm not in a position to
make any decisions on those issues anyway.
There's one, as I said, one president at a
time and he will be president until January
20th.
It would be nice to have it, but it's not
critical.
And that's we're just going to proceed the
way we have.
We're going to we're going to do exactly what
we'd be doing if he had conceded and said
we have one, which we have.
And so there's nothing really changing, but
not ruling out legal action.
So I don't see a need for legal action.
Quite frankly.
I think the legal action is you're seeing
it play out, the actions he's taking.
And so far, there is no evidence of any of
the assertions made by the president or Secretary
of State Powell, Secretary of State Colin
Powell.
So the calm is commendable and the laugh at
the end is just perfect as far as optics go.
But what is really interesting to understand
is that as the narcissistic egomaniac that
is Donald Trump, narcissistic egomaniacs want
other people to be mad and they want other
people to be afraid.
We've talked to all sorts of different psychologists
and others on the program over the last four
years.
And they have explained and this is widely
written about in literature, in psychology,
literature, that narcissists and these sort
of egomaniacs like Donald Trump, they control
situations by getting the other person angry,
by getting the other person rattled.
And so Joe Biden just laughing it off and
moving full steam ahead with the transition
and a coronavirus task force and the some
of the same reporters who normally would be
sitting in the press briefing room asking
Trump questions are now at Joe Biden's press
conference.
This has to be enraging Donald Trump.
Now, Joe Biden was asked versions of that
same question, including does what Donald
Trump is doing hurt your transition plan?
Does what Donald Trump is doing affect your
ability to do?
ABC and Joe Biden just very calmly saying
we're moving ahead.
Donald Trump's behavior is not affecting my
transition.
I'm the president elect.
I'm moving forward.
Thank you, Mr. President elect.
During the campaign, you said you were not
naive about how difficult it would be to unite
the country.
It's now three days after you were projected
as the president elect.
The president himself says he has won this
election.
His own administration has not moved forward
to give you access to what you need to do
to begin the work of your transition.
Just a few minutes ago, the secretary of state
when asked if he would.
Cooperate with a smooth transition, he said
there will be a smooth transition to a second
Trump administration.
I wonder if you have a message for the president
who may well be watching right now, and how
do you expect to be able to work with Republicans
when so many have thus far refused to even
acknowledge your victory?
Well, first of all, we are at the beginning
of the transition.
We're well underway.
And the ability for the administration in
any way by failing to recognize this is our
win does not change the dynamic at all and
what we're able to do.
And then Joe Biden interestingly, pointed
out that he thinks Republicans are standing
by Trump because they're scared or intimidated
by him.
And there's a lot of interesting stuff to
discuss there as well.
Mr. President elect Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell has suggested today that he
may not recognize the outcome of this election
until the Electoral College meets next month.
Have you spoken to your long time friend in
the Senate, Mr. McConnell?
And what do you make of his specific comments
over the last 24 hours?
I haven't had a chance to speak to Mitch.
My expectation is that I will do that not
too distant future.
I think that the whole Republican Party has
been put in a position with a few notable
exceptions, of being mildly intimidated by
the sitting president.
Yeah, what's interesting about that and our
friend Bill Share and others have been tweeting
about this, it is very interesting that even
as a loser, Republicans still seem to be under
the thumb of Donald Trump.
Now, this could be for a few different reasons.
There could be Republicans who still think
maybe Trump gets another four years.
And so I should sort of stay on his good side.
It could be that it's merely concern over
the Georgia Senate races.
And once those are done, they will bail on
Trump.
Now, of course, at that point, it will only
be 15 days until Trump leaves office.
I don't know.
We streamed this event live and many of our
viewers reacted to Biden's calm by saying
Biden being calm is making me calm.
When Trump is manic and going crazy, my blood
pressure goes up.
This is a lot of our viewers.
Biden being so calm is making me calm, which
is interesting.
And then lastly, here's Joe Biden making the
point that Trump not conceding makes Trump
look bad in bringing up the idea of Trump's
legacy.
Sir, what do you say to the Americans that
are anxious over the fact that President Trump
has yet to concede and what that might mean
for the country?
Well, I just think it's an embarrassment,
quite frankly.
The only thing that how can I say this tactfully?
I think it will not help the president's legacy.
I think that I know from my discussions with
foreign leaders thus far that they are hopeful
that the United States democratic institutions
are viewed once again as being strong and
enduring.
Given how Donald Trump has been behaving,
it would actually be completely appropriate
for Joe Biden to attack Donald Trump, and
it would be totally appropriate for Joe Biden
to go after Donald Trump in a more serious
way.
And yet he didn't.
We are not going to agree with Joe Biden on
policy, on nearly everything.
But there is a change in the air.
Since Joe Biden was declared president elect
by networks, it's been palpable.
And even many who did not vote for Biden in
the primary, but ultimately did vote for Joe
Biden in in the general election with some
skepticism, have emailed me and said, you
know, it's not about policy right now.
I'm finding Joe's demeanor in the face of
unhinged insanity from Trump and endless conspiracy
theories from the right.
I'm finding Joe Biden's demeanor to be the
right fit for the time.
Let's hope it continues.
And we have so much more to talk about today
about the conspiracy theories and the allegations
and so much more, including Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo asked about the fact that there's
been no acknowledgment of Joe Biden's when
Mike Pompeo saying there will be a smooth
transition to a second Trump administration.
That's coming up a little bit later.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter,
where you can find me at department T